Is there anything about your genetic code that would ever make you
change your mind or change reproductive decisions for yourself in any way?
>> Well in the Jewish community, Tay-Sachs, is an issue.
I don't know how many people are aware of that. But.
>> Just really quick, can you tell us what Tay-Sachs is?
>> Tay-Sachs is in the same family as Gaucher's disease,
which is one of the diseases that I have, it's a lipid storage disease. And in
Tay-Sachs babies, the lipid accumulates in the brain, and the
baby dies within a short period of time. And they, under two years old, usually,
typically. And there is no treatment, and it's pretty much erradicated,
because either people don't marry who are pre-tested
before, I'm talking about the orthadox Jewish community, where people
are tested beore marriage. And they
wouldn't have an abortion, so it prevents two people who carry that
mutation from getting married and having a child who would die in a.
>> Which
is interesting because in my community we, we come into the union knowing
full well what our options are and many still go through with it.
>> You know, this is interesting because, so, Tay-Sachs is a recessive trait.
>> Right. Right.
>> And Achondroplasia is a dominant trait, which means
that in the Tay Sachs world having, being a carrier
means you're not affected. whereas in the case of
Achondroplasia, if you're a carrier it means you are affected,
you're affected as a carrier. so, I, I'm interested to hear these sort of
slightly different perspectives here, on the ability
to sort of think and, and plan.
>> Well, with a Tay-Sachs baby, the baby is going to die. I mean
that's, that's the story today. I don't know if that will be the case in the
future. I never knew that I was a Tay-Sachs carrier until now, and I'm not
having any more children, and it my husband would have to be a carrier as well.
but
there are people in the Jewish community who would test. Maybe at a
later weeks, I don't know what the right time and it is to test
>> Uh-huh.
>> For any genetic diseases or any situations and I
guess its a decision at that time of what to do.
>> I think I am, I just based on the
information I already have. Nothing would affect, it's kind of a,
at this point because of the results that I have
from 23 and me, nothing would really impact my decision
to have children. It's more of a, my wife works
in biology, and it's really fun doing the Punnett squares
[LAUGH]
between our possibilities of what kids are. Fun for her, I think.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> But, so, yeah, I think you know I
can't speak for, if something were there, I don't know
what I would do, that's kind of one of those
things that I think you have to cross that bridge
>> When you get there.
>> When you get there, and it is impossible to predict what I might, what
how different, if things have been different. I
don't know how it would have affected anything.